Kamala Harris was speaking at some silly
event and she went off on the Dismal
state of education in America not the
test scores not the fact that students
don't know anything but on those evil
Republican Governors like Ron DeSantis
who are
Banning
think about where we've been in the last
few years in terms of everything from
anti-asian hate crime the attacks we're
seeing where there are literally can you
imagine in this year of Our Lord 2023
book bands I mean really like like what
book bands book bands can you I mean
like like like seriously like what like
like
book bands I am so pleased to learn that
vice president Kamala Harris I love Venn
diagrams has turned against her party
and she has come out in favor of the
Bible in schools that's so great I'm so
happy she deserves to be applauded for
that